we begin with breaking news out of Syria
the Turkish Defense Ministry says four
Turkish soldiers have been killed by
Syrian government shelling nine others
were wounded in the attack and Edler
province on Sunday the Turkish military
sent reinforcements to northern Syria
and it warned it may intervene against
the government's offensive in Aleppo and
Idlib city mikoshi Oulu joins us now on
the phone live from Istanbul soon and
what more can you tell us who alias
Turkish military has used a have been
sending reinforcements to it before the
last couple of days and it was
intensified yesterday as Turkey was
planning to establish a military post
and observation cost around serikov area
because as the Syrian government
advanced from south to north in at least
three of the 12 Turkish military
observation posts our current cities are
surrounded by the Syrian government
forces and the displacement is ongoing
that's why at the a mostly new military
coast was to stop clearing government
advance towards Western Aleppo mainly to
the Surat repair to the area of the
rocket where there are Syrian civilians
so we yesterday we have witnessed that
Turkish convoys Turkish reinforcements
have been attacked by a Syrian
government sections which are mainly the
Shia militia groups as the military
called them but in the early morning
hours it seems there are four Turkish
soldiers that have been killed
this is at first because the 2000 i
agreement this never happened yesterday
military posts have been harassed by the
Syrian government's actions this year a
fighter group yes Turkish convoys have
been attacked by the same groups before
and turkey retaliated in the same scale
but exceeded yesterday and then this
morning was something different and
let's not forget everything is happening
despite Astana and Sochi peace process
that was signed under the Goron to issue
a graduation of a Russia and Iran I have
spoken to some military sources they
early in the morning and they they were
stunned as well as see 50
government is now trying to push the
opposition for a military solution
rather than a political solution that
has been that has been transferred to
Geneva coat that you know currently
there is the committee at this hundred
system members are there they are trying
to write a new constitution of Syria
which will allow all citizens of Syria
the same right but many now argue that
the Syrian government is not abiding by
this is not actually supporting the
constitutional court process of course
this incident is very important because
turkey and Russia has been on the same
page inside Syria for a while despite
bilateral political and diplomatic
crisis like shutting both sides each
other just inside over Syria but now
people are afraid whether Russia and
Turkey will confront each other or
Turkish army will direct the confront
and Syrian army which could which could
be made a real war that done because so
far all the harassment came through the
and she has fighter groups which were
under control of the Syrian government
the Syrian government has never directly
affected a Turkish army but we know that
as the Syrian government has advanced
inside Syria and has gained back its
territory from from the Syrian
opposition health areas and other areas
and now they are pushing tricky to
evacuate the military posts into the
escalation zone which is a bit and let's
not forget Turkey is in the D
escalations on the 12th military
observation post upon the request of the
Syrian government and under the
mediation of Russia and Turkey says you
invited me here why should I leave right
now unless there's a real political
solution with the Syrian opposition and
also this goes for the same as in
schools the same way and for the other
territories that are under the control
of the Syrian opposition which - which
is backed by the Syrian and by the
Turkish army that is called or olive
branch areas and
other other area so now it's the risk
that those areas are going to be
destabilized but of course presidents
are John is going to fly to Ukraine
today and within a few hours and he's
expected to speak before his flight so
the messages that he's going to deliver
before flying to acquaint are going to
be very important absolutely thank you
so much for that we'll have to leave it
there for now they'd seen him course
although they're live from Istanbul
thank you